it feels weird to say but it's having
lower expectations here's what happens
when you have really high expectations
then when you don't do it you lose a
little more self-confidence yeah so then
the next time you say you're going to do
something you're like yeah I'm probably
not going to do that either because
you've kind of trained yourself that
when you say you're going to do
something you don't follow through it's
still having the vision it's not like
don't have a big vision for your life
and where you can go it's like still
having a vision for what you could do
and the impact you want to have and the
lives you want to change you're gearing
towards some huge thing that is
impossible to do and that's amazing
we're trying to change the world and
then today being a lot smaller the
problem is for Achievers it feels like
it's not enough it's like I used to be
able to do all this stuff and now like
the bar is so low that I'm only like
researching and watching One video and
seeing if that's going to be a good
website host for me but that's the
process of rebuilding confidence it's
better to over achieve on super small
goals than to underachieve on your big
goals because then it teaches you you
that you won't follow through the next
time
I'm not at the beginning of my
entrepreneur Journey but I took a really
long break because I wasn't well and so
getting back
into doing it and doing something a
little bit different feels intimidating
and I've been trying to get back
for such a long time that even the
thought even it just gets me like I get
overthink things get caught up my
confidence isn't really great anymore so
that's what I need help with is getting
back and doing things I used to be
really confident in you know doing
things was like oh yeah let's just have
the idea get it sorted get it out there
and now that doesn't seem to be
happening is in the same way
I hear you uh I've been I think we've
all been on roller coasters like that's
part of the entrepreneurial journey is
the the ups and downs and ups and downs
and the trick for me at least is anytime
I'm in a low is to actually be gentler
on myself and more kind and not to
expect the same level of output as what
I had before because if I'm living in
the past like if I'm really down because
something happened to compare myself to
Evan from whatever year when I was
crushing it and ambitious uh it only
makes things worse it only like destroys
the confidence even more as opposed to
helping me so
um whether it's a physical like when I
broke my neck in 2019
like I couldn't get out of bed
like sitting up by myself was a win
not not asking my wife Nina to help me
like be my crutch so that I can go pee
was a win right let alone like speaking
and writing books and doing my tour and
like making videos and right like that
was the win just getting up and not
needing help to go to the bathroom was a
win right yeah so I don't know what you
know kind of Health Journey you know
you've been through or coming through
um but it's just being more gentle on
yourself that you did the best you could
with what you had and still are trying
to do the best you can with what you
have and you can get back to where you
were and Beyond uh but it's a process
and it's okay if it's not like tomorrow
that you're not instantly better and
healed and crushing it
yeah yeah
I think I think my expectation always is
oh yeah today's the day
that it's gonna all be okay and
everything's gonna like met it's been a
long time like many years so it's been
like I think
uh where's the word like logistically
like you know like in my head I want to
be like this
and my body's like well we're still not
there yet and um so yeah so there's like
there is a bit of that expectation and
then it just kind of turns into but I'm
gonna do this today and then it gets
away and
um nothing happens right yeah so
honestly it's having uh it feels weird
to say but it's having lower
expectations so that you can actually
achieve it and so
um here's what happens like when you
have really high expectations then when
you don't do it that you lose a little
more self-confidence and like every time
you say you're gonna do something and
then you don't do it you lose more
self-confidence yeah so then the next
time you say you're gonna do something
you're like yeah I'm probably not going
to do that either because you've kind of
trained yourself that when you say
you're gonna do something you don't
follow through yes yeah yeah or I have
like you know the plans there's the
plans like do all the home like take the
courses do all the homework on all the
courses
and then the implementation doesn't
follow through you know in
so it's it's still having the vision
it's not like don't have a big vision
for your life and where you can go it's
like still having a vision for what you
could do and the impact you want to have
and the lives you want to change like
you're you're gearing towards some huge
thing that is impossible to do and
that's amazing like we're trying to
change the world and then today being
a lot smaller it's like okay my goal
like you showed up today this is great
and it was so last minute it was like
what two days I have to two days before
I get wet
but you could have said hey I'm uh I'm
not feeling well or I'm not ready or I'm
sick or I've got like whatever like you
could you could have said that and we
would have rescheduled hey no problem
Joy like we'll find but you didn't and
you're here yeah this is a win right
we're building momentum yes yeah and so
like feel that feel the feel the joy of
you showed up and you did it yeah
whether you have like the perfect
question or whatever like it started off
great we're looking at your computer
like how do I do this it's great
like because I thought I was ready yeah
yeah like we're winning that that's the
process and so if every day you were
just to say okay tomorrow I've got blank
and I'm gonna this is what I'm gonna
show up for tomorrow
and then you actually do that thing so
yesterday is like okay tomorrow I'm
going to show up for the Instagram live
with Evan Carmichael and you did it and
that's a win and so we're celebrating
today and so tomorrow what's what's the
win that like think about what you have
to do what you could do what is an
actual win for you for tomorrow
obviously because when I yeah that's a
really good question because immediately
I'm gonna build my website like start to
finish it's gonna be done which is like
that was a little bit high expectations
to build a brand new website start to
finish until it's done and perfect and
beautiful that's um that's uh that's a
project
I would love to have my
mind done great joy so that's great so
just take that concept and think of it
like you're gonna floss one tooth the
goal is a floss one tooth and if you
show up and you've lost one tooth cool
like you hit your goal
but you're probably going to do a little
bit more anyway yeah right like you're
probably not just gonna floss one tooth
you're probably going to floss a lot
more and maybe all of it so take that
website example cool so tomorrow is it
is it do you have time in your calendar
with your life and your health and the
family and you know everything that you
got going on do you have a block of time
tomorrow that you can focus on building
your website
yeah
cool what what time is reasonable for
you to work on the website I don't know
time time blocks aren't easy like I just
don't work in
I've tried to do that like this time
block I'm gonna do this I don't I need
to find another is there another way
there must be another way of organizing
a day instead of like time blocks when
time isn't something that I work
easily with
okay so you're gonna show up tomorrow
you've got some commitments I don't mean
to do what life and morning routines or
whatever like you're gonna wake up at
some point maybe it's not consistent
across every day how do you decide what
you're going to do tomorrow you just
wake up and say I'm feeling what I'm
going to work on like how do you how do
you figure out your day
um generally well I always have a list
of too many things I want to get done
well we're going to fix that yeah sure
there's my bullet Journal there's the
list
um so yeah so there's an idea of the
things I want to get done so I wake up
do my morning routines and then
yeah I'm not really very good with
routines I mean I've gotten better doing
habits and consistently doing things but
I'm not really good with block time or
sitting down when I have a project even
if I have it written down it just kind
of falls out of my head of things I need
to be doing because something else comes
along oh look I need to take care of
that well we just need to simplify
especially at the beginning
to start building the new habits like if
you have never worked out going into the
gym and saying I'm going to list 800
pounds it's not gonna like you're gonna
break your back trying to do that do you
go in and you lose five pounds you know
four times and then you put the weights
down and tomorrow you show up and you
can carry a little bit more right so
yeah so tomorrow is it a crazy day for
you do you have a ton of commitments or
family or health things you gotta you
have a doctor's appointment you have
like there's nothing no it's pretty open
okay to what I want to do mostly like
every day because I never know what's
gonna happen Okay
so so having like a to-do list is great
you know like it helps you set some
priorities now it's moving it to an
action list so that tomorrow or even
maybe this afternoon you know is it are
you on East Coast where are you I'm in
I'm on the west coast oh okay so it's
only it's 11 A.M for you right now yeah
it's early we still have time there's
time left today to do something so we
can even plan it for today instead of
tomorrow yeah you look at your to-do
list has a million things on it that all
need to get done and you and you want to
do them cool what
one thing from that to-do list could you
move to an action list that's going to
happen today so if it's website
underneath website is a million things
like there's tons of to figure finish
your website it's not just a bunch of
text and throw it on a page and you're
done so inside website websites on your
to-do list what do we move to our action
list that you can do this afternoon like
what is a what is a reasonable thing
that once we're done this call
we're going to take some action on our
website that you can actually complete
today that's the equivalent of flossing
one tooth it's just the first step
um
I think reading I I I've been a
WordPress person for a long time and
then it just instead of
WordPress getting easier it seemed to
have gotten more complicated over time
which seemed like oh I don't want to do
this anymore I wanted it to be easy
and so I found a web host that has a
drag and drop thing so I need to look at
the instructions okay the first what
what's what's the web host name
uh name cheat
so namecheap has a built-in web designer
that's drag and drop
cool so that's like that gets moved to
action list
and the goal today is to research and
understand namecheaps training
and maybe by the end of it you realize
named sheep is the best thing ever and
like wow this is so cool or maybe
realize wow this sucks and it's actually
not as easy as I thought it was going to
be yeah
but so the goal of today like we have
our to-do list with a million things
awesome the action list for today is
figure out namecheap
yeah I have a backup plan to that
because I do have a lifetime for uh for
Divi and so namecheap also gives you the
option of having like the web hosting by
them or
doing whatever and so I do have Divi on
the background just in case but so the
goal today though is just figure out if
namecheap the the right option that's it
that's our goal yeah that's our
philosophy one truth and maybe you
figure that out in 20 minutes after
watching One training or maybe it takes
you three hours of going through it to
kind of figure it out but the idea is
this is the goal for the rest of the day
that if you hit that it's like hey pat
on the back like I said
a goal and I hit it I said I was gonna
do it and I did it
okay and if you complete that you can
always add more you can always
you know what I'm gonna try actually
building my website instead of just
researching I'm going to try just making
a home page and just playing around with
some text and maybe doing but it's not
the requirement
for the day
um okay
so we're lowering we still got a big
vision and big mission to what we can
accomplish but we're lowering our
expectations for what we want to do
today because we don't want to train
ourselves that you set goals and then
don't follow through and then you feel
like you know you don't feel great
because you said you're going to do 10
things and you did like half of one
um
exactly yeah or I missed or missed any
any of my markers of doing any of the
things yeah
so like one me that's the easiest way to
start building
momentum and rebuild your confidence is
one thing every day that you're going to
be working on towards building this
business for yourself and a realistic
like if you know that you're gonna you
have some wedding to go to tomorrow or a
doctor's appointment that's going to
take a chunk of your day or like don't
put some giant thing on when you know
there's some other crazy thing happening
for the day right right but if you know
your days open even your your like
you're willing to take action because I
was saying tomorrow and he's like well I
got today he's like I love it
today that's great let's go today right
and so it's just picking one thing every
day from to-do list to action the to-do
list is like the ideas of the things
that have to get done and it's you've
got your vision list of like the world
the big impact you want to change in the
world but a lot of that is like you
don't know you have no idea how it's
going to happen the to-do list is the
okay these are some of the steps that I
think will work out but then the action
list is okay like today here's what I'm
working on or tomorrow here's what I'm
working on whatever kind of flows best
some people is better at night to kind
of figure out okay tomorrow here's my
one thing that I'm going to focus on
or maybe for you it's the morning of
you know you're meditating or sitting in
the garden or sipping your coffee or
whatever he's like okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna work on this today whether it's
like night before or morning of to
decide just what's that one action that
you're gonna take today but then you're
going to celebrate yourself for instead
of beating yourself up for all the
things on your two lists that you like
didn't get done
yeah that that's familiar yes yes
um yeah that's a really good thing yeah
there's I do lots of other things but
the things that I want yes it's a matter
of getting the things that I want to get
done
um because I know I've heard you talk
and movement makers a lot about getting
on there doing the YouTube videos just
getting out there and speaking and I'm
like I did videos not my thing what are
you doing videos not your thing so that
kind of holds me back from doing video
when I feel like video is not my thing
um
what do you do then
well it's still content like what's your
message that you want to get up to the
world uh videos just the the most
prevalent because YouTube Instagram all
the platforms are going to video first
but you could still post content if you
love the written word maybe you start
crushing it on Twitter and you start
sharing your one-liners or your
inspiration maybe you take your
um you could take some pictures and put
it on Instagram with with a great copy
that go with each one it's still just
the idea of content creation
um but that doesn't necessarily have to
be like again build the baby steps to
build the foundation of confidence again
to teach yourself that you
you can get back to where you used to be
and more
so don't stress out about like I need
now I need to
get my website done and I need to post
on Twitter and Instagram and take
pictures and write beautiful coffee
because then now we've made our actual
as a giant and then and nothing happens
and then you stress out again over why
you can't do it right like again when I
broke my neck I wasn't even thinking
about making content or my next speaking
gig or being behind and write my book or
I I mean I told everybody in my life at
the time like hey this happened and I am
not going to be as responsible and I'm
gonna drop a whole bunch of balls and
like I can't even look at my phone or a
screen for more than five seconds
because I have a concussion like sorry
guys I can't do this right now and
that's okay
and if if anybody's like well screw you
I need you to do it's like okay well
maybe you're not a good fit for how we
should be doing business together right
um and slowly I added more things back
in
um even in micro moments like that's a
major events uh and I don't know the
health issues that you went through but
it sounds like it was a pretty major
event it wasn't just like you got cold
and you're better the next day right
um but even in micro moments like
two nights ago I didn't sleep very well
and so
okay I gave myself a little more like a
little more grace for the day
but I don't I'm not going to do as much
today because I'm gonna I'm gonna rest
because if I if I go crazy today and I
didn't sleep then I'm gonna I'm gonna
like really suffer tomorrow I might get
sick so it's micro adjustments too
sometimes when you need it not just like
big events when there's a Health crisis
or a family crisis or if somebody passes
away or something happens with your kids
or you know like all those things will
happen that might be major life changes
um but even in the micro like last night
I slept great
so it's like let's go today come on we
got stuff to do let's go change the
world I'm excited come on let's add more
to the action list there's all the
energy from that yeah yeah yeah I mean
sleep matters a lot and but it's okay if
like last night
um
I may not have as much energy if I did
sleep as well and I may not have and
that's okay
um
it's okay to have a little more grace
for yourself
um yeah
so yeah macro events that might change
you know like life-changing events might
be a little harder to bounce back from
that's okay and also the little micro
things that you know you have to bounce
back from that's okay like if something
happens
um and you didn't sleep as well but cool
can you still make a little bit of
progress on your website like can you
still
test out drag in and dropping a picture
in or putting some copy or looking up
how to how do I launch a Twitter account
you know if you don't have one or how do
I can I post one thing on Instagram
today
and and it feels like nothing it feels
the problem is for Achievers it feels
like it's not enough
it's like I used to be able to do all
this stuff and now like the bar is so
low that I'm only like researching and
watching One video and seeing if that's
going to be a good website host for me
um but that's the process of rebuilding
confidence like it's better to do it's
better to over achieve on super small
goals than to underachieve on your big
goals because then it teaches you that
you won't follow through the next time
yeah yeah that's a really valid point I
think when I was so I have multiple
chemical sensitivity which means that
um like somebody's laundry or yep
exhaust bars or like a myriad of things
right so neighbor's laundry starts doing
their laundry and the exhaust from their
vent comes out it's like everybody runs
around the house and closes all the
windows and by that point it's like
where's my you know causes brain fog and
then well I can't really do very much a
whole lot of brain fog and I'm doing a
lot better now but sometimes like
yesterday I was just taken right out and
I was literally paralyzed while in the
park because something happened yeah
came by and I'm like well what do I do
now I can't go anywhere literally so
it's like so that's why I don't plan
anything because it's just I just never
know
so listen so something like that like I
I do too I had um Alex on my team he
helps me run Toronto Dan salsa came over
on Monday and he had really strong
cologne on for whatever reason and I'm I
walk upstairs he's in my kitchen it's
like holy cow I cannot like for most
people it's not a big deal I guess but I
couldn't breathe I could not breathe so
we had our meeting but I sat at my patio
with the window open like in front of
the screen with just freezing cold air
on me just to get fresh air and like a
blanket and a heat pad
for us to have the meeting and then he
went home afterwards it's like don't
work here because that's like we'll
still have our meeting I need Fresh Air
Blast into my face and for most people
it's like that's not a big deal it's
just a little bit of cologne but for me
it's like I couldn't concentrate like
can't I'm getting a headache in eight
seconds so so we adjusted you know
around that and then he went home and
you know he's like next time hopefully
he doesn't wear a really strong cologne
when he's like I gotta put a sign on my
door like the doctor's office like don't
wear no strong reviews or cologne
um
him him sit outside and you're inside
right that should have been that it
doesn't stay in your house because it's
staying in your house otherwise that is
the point I love it Alex I need to send
in this video so that hopefully next
time he doesn't even wear anything
um well let him know yeah yeah you know
he definitely knows
like if you're not you're not a follow
through on something
then you have to be proud of the reason
why I feel like that's the key so you
say you're gonna you're gonna work on
your website today and if you don't then
you have to be proud of the reason why
it's like okay but like the the exhaust
went off and I was on the floor for half
the day so I couldn't do it as long as
like nobody else can let you off the
hook
you know it's if you're if you're okay
with the reason why then then it's okay
then you don't lose your confidence you
know if like I'm proud of how I did that
thing without I'm still gonna have this
meeting I'm gonna suffer I'm going to be
cold I'm going to have a blanket and a
heat pad on me and my dogs on me warming
me up and we're still having this
meeting like that's how I I'll feel
confident about myself that I said I was
gonna do it and we're gonna do it I
could have been smarter I could have
sent him outside that's a much better
solution Joey than what I came up with
but like at least in my head to myself I
still did it we still had the meeting we
still made progress right
um if if he knocked me out like if if I
couldn't find a solution and just that's
it I'm done for the day that's okay I
mean I had I don't know seven other
meetings afterwards and if I had to
cancel on them because I couldn't show
up then I would tell them guys like I
can't focus right now I'm no good to you
in a meeting I need to
sit outside or meditate or nap or cold
shower or whatever and I'm okay with the
reason why it's not because I'm not
motivated or I don't believe I can it's
like I'm physically unable to do this
thing so as long as you're proud of the
reason why you're not doing it it's not
because you're overthinking or over
planning you just physically can't do
the thing because that situation
happened and kind of Knocked you on the
ground that's okay
I'm it's really much better after
talking with you
I'm doing this like I feel like I do
this alone in my own yeah just alone
because there's a lot of isolation
because I can't go anywhere but you know
like just literally alone all the time
like with this oh yeah I can't do this
and I can't do that and
it's discouraging but I'm feeling one
thing and yeah that just being
um
just like what you said about being
proud of the reason it's like it's okay
I if I can't do that right now you know
I remember I was on I was visiting the
city and uh I went into a bookstore it
was like a super old bookstore like
really really old book and the dust was
insane and I've got crazy dust allergies
and so I was walking through there and I
started sneezing and I I try to just
stay with my wife who like for whatever
reason I don't know how she didn't
notice or like she wasn't suffering at
all like what anyway and then like that
ruined my entire afternoon just sneezing
and the sneezing lets a giant headache
and I couldn't focus on other things
like okay I can't keep going around the
city and and so it's fine like
I physically can't go off and do it
that's okay uh but not because I don't
want to or I'm not capable of you know
like I'm just overthinking over planning
um and now I have a better strategy for
next time like as soon as I go into a
into a store and it smells crazy Dusty
I'm out like you go you spend as much
time as you want in there brows peruse
don't feel like I'm holding you back
spend two hours in there if you want I'm
gonna sit outside and do something else
because that's gonna cause some crazy
chaos for me
um
so you get better strategies but you
know in the moment if that happens then
it's okay to let yourself it's not like
letting yourself off the hook but let
yourself
um
you know again you're proud of the
reason why it's okay like you're
physically not able to do it instead of
beating yourself up
yeah it's honoring where we're at
instead of feeling like
you know feeling dismissive or angry or
you know berating because oh well I
guess I'm not you know fill in the blank
good enough worthy and you know whatever
um
yeah
yeah exactly
it's accessible now everybody uses masks
you know you have better Solutions than
me this is great you know
I wish I thought of that uh I I suffered
and struggled walking through there you
know I didn't I didn't want to make a
scene or didn't want to make them make
you know them feel bad or whatever but
meanwhile I'm suffering and struggling
that's so hard and then your eyes start
watering
it's like once it gets to my headache
and like I can deal with physical pain
of sneezing and it's annoying or
whatever but once you like are holding
your sneeze so much that then yeah the
headache then that's where like crazy
migraine issues growing up uh that's
when it gets hard to focus it's like I
can't I can't see the screen I can't
how am I supposed to do a blank right
and so yeah that's okay like at that
point okay it's okay maybe the whole day
is gone and you start again tomorrow
maybe you just need a two hour break
maybe you just need to close your eyes
and and meditate or wash your face out
or neti pot or like you know maybe you
come back to it or maybe not but as long
as you're proud of the reason why like
you did your best you tried it's not for
lack of effort there's there's an actual
legitimate like physical reason why you
can't do the thing
yeah yeah for sure oh I'm feeling so
much
okay before before we close what's
what's the quote on your wall behind you
um it says life is it life isn't
measured by the number of breaths we
take
but by the moments that take our breath
away
I like it which is great if you don't
have like somebody in your room with
cologne and you can't breathe yeah well
true then it's measured by how many
breaths that I'm taking
well thank you Joey thank you for the
love thank you for being part of
movement makers and um happy looking at
your website today I'm excited for you
what's your process to always keep
believing in yourself what a start this
is great step one is just it's more
action you know like if you're
overthinking and you're stuck in in not
believing in yourself it just go off and
do it like that idea that you've got I
expect it to suck I mean if you talk
about it in in you know momentum like I
expected something brand new I expected
this I expect me to suck at doing that
thing I expect no results to come I just
expect it to suck and I I just love
pushing through on momentum
um
default to action more action you get an
idea like how much can you do while
you're in that zone like I wrote that
book in five days when I had no time to
write a book
um I just came back from speaking in
Arizona and San Diego and arrived on
what arrived two days ago and I was
thinking with Nick who's who's on our
team doing a lot of the marketing stuff
and
okay what are we going to do with like
now right here while we're here like not
when we get home not next week not when
we've got more times like what what are
we doing right now we met up into
Starbucks in the morning and and mapped
the whole thing out
so whatever the thing is that you're
struggling with or the ideas that you
come up with it's like what what is the
Massive Action you can just default to
doing right now more like create more
because inside of the Massive Action
maybe not everything works out but
there's a seed of something and one
thing starts to to lift off I don't
beside the IG live I did with uh with
kale a couple days ago but awesome uh
young 17 year old uh guy who wants to
become a singer like okay cool 30-day
challenge I want you to make a new song
every day for 30 days do do uh like five
covers and then an original song uh and
I basically at the point for what it
should be doing every day and
and he's been doing it he's on day five
or six right now through the challenge
right and not all the songs have taken
out but one of them has 800 or 900 views
now which for him is huge because he's
he's just getting started he's like wow
I got 800 900 views on one video
this is where most people will fall
apart is that the video that got the 800
900 views for him was not his first one
it was like the third or fourth one
and we tend to put so much expectations
on that first thing working out as
opposed to say I'm just gonna I'm gonna
make Massive Action and one of these
things will pan out
so whatever the thing is on your list
you go and you make and you create and
like when you're in action mode you're
not in overthinking mode
because you're doing
so especially at the beginning
so is there like is there an idea that
you want to work on like why did why
this question sometimes I need to to to
Really choose what are the dreams that I
want to pursue because I'm always you
know thinking on stuff the first thing
is my job it's always my you know my
family my job because my job is what I
love to do and also what you know allows
me to to maintain my family so that's a
big thing and um and it also it is all
connected to my passion which is working
with immigrants so I'm doing that I'm
also working on my YouTube channel and
uh and and
um there's also a salsa a salsa group
that
I'm also working on that like so we can
learn to to lead and to follow at both
at the same time
um and uh my project with women so those
are kind of the main things it's uh
except with the salsa uh group it's all
connected to the Immigrant world and
today to
um to the to the to my work somehow and
what happens sometimes and I don't
normally see that with me but many many
times with my clients is that um there
are many
many times when you feel that your
circumstances start to be like too big
or you know like there's no
sometimes it's like you feel that there
there's not enough you to do all the
things that you want
so you start feeling a little bit
um frustrated in the sense that okay I'm
not being able to do as much as I want
I'm doing it but maybe I'm going too
slowly or maybe I'm not uh doing as good
as I wish I can do stuff and for at
least for me one of my biggest things is
big I don't want to disappoint those
that I care about uh so you know I try
to deliver in whatever I get I try to
deliver but sometimes it's like because
of the circumstances again you know uh
the you know the the time constraints
and many responsibilities the the nature
of the demands I have sometimes I feel
like a little bit overwhelmed and uh
start feeling like okay so am I enough
to do all these dreams that I have and
just today I was talking to a client in
the morning and he was having the same
thing the same feelings like okay I'm
here now I'm in this country it's great
but now I'm feeling that I'm I'm just
I'm just not being able to go to the
places or do the things that I wanted
because I don't know if I'm you know how
I'm gonna deal with everything so that's
kind of like the process I'm trying to
to extract from you how do you organize
you know how how do you manage to
being able to deal and go beyond your
circumstances so I don't um
I would I would put personally I'll put
them in two different categories right
circumstances versus feeling overwhelmed
in the circumstances it's recognizing
that people with weight less than you
have done way more like be around your
Heroes more who have you looked up to
look at what they've done you have no
reason why you can't do it too and so I
surround myself with my heroes through
the videos that I mostly videos
um sometimes books or shows but like the
videos themselves if I see Oprah and
what she went through of
look she's a great reminder for me of
she was sexually abused and didn't have
great parents and grew up most with her
grandmother and uh
was so poor that she had to go to school
in a potato sack like her grandmother
couldn't afford so you know like imagine
going to school in a potato bag
and you think you have problems right
and then she became Oprah so
what's your excuse right this is what I
would tell myself he's like well we're
now in 2022 going into 2023. the
resources that you have you have the
internet like you have so much more
opportunity than even your parents had
at your age and so
it's just perspective and looking out
and looking at whoever your heroes are
they started with less than what you
have right now
and so it's not an issue of circumstance
it's deciding that it's not an issue of
circumstance right so that one doesn't
usually get me tripped up too much for
overwhelm
uh
I'll go through phases of
I get an idea
immediate action I don't stress out
about like I think you get overwhelmed
because you have to figure out all of
the is either you have to figure out the
whole plan
like I want to start this thing I don't
know how to how to do it we focus so
much on the how of this big idea that
then it blocks us from creating
and so instead of focusing on the on the
fully mapped out how I'll focus on what
I have to do right now
at the at the event that I just came
back from I I came up with some ideas of
these new shows that I wanted to start I
want to start a new Regular Show uh for
the Gaming Community for the nft
community
um for the entrepreneur community and
those last ones there's four shows that
I want to start and I get inspired while
I'm in the middle of somebody's talk
so for the next
I don't know two hours all I'm all I'm
doing is is messaging people who I think
might be a good fit for the show like
I'm not paying attention anymore to the
speaker I'm not worried about anything
else going on and I'm just okay I need
to get this show up what does it look
like what technology we're going to use
there's gonna be Zoom or something now I
don't know I like don't work because you
can't map out the whole plan
it's just getting started what's the
first step I need I need to find
somebody to do the show with me
so that's my next step and then that day
I met somebody uh in my nft community at
a at a cafe to talk about it that night
I got on a zoom call with someone in
Gaming Community to talk about it and I
met with somebody at the event to talk
in the entrepreneurial Community about
doing something together it's like
immediate action on the thing
something that would have taken that
could have taken months or years or some
people to think through like who's gonna
be the perfect fit and on and what did
they say no what if they don't like me
or what if I'm not good enough or like
all the what-ifs get solved by just
doing stuff
I know right so just creating
the second part so that's like the first
if the overwhelm is I don't know how I'm
gonna make this thing then default to
just immediate action because your how
is not going to work out anyway like the
how you think you're going to accomplish
your goal right now is not how it's
actually going to be so so don't waste
time thinking about how it's all going
to work out just start doing it and the
plan will will be created as you go like
you can only really plan one or two
steps out not all the way so the
overwhelm is coming from
how am I going to reach the goal then
that's not a good use of any mental
energy and default to just more
immediate action if the overwhelm is I'm
doing too many things
then it's cutting down some of the
things
maybe maybe the salsa group's not the
thing you want to do anymore I don't
know I love science but maybe right but
it's like when I went away on my trip
uh I came back and I stopped the the
gaming channel
so I don't know if you've ever joined
our gaming channel but I was I was
gaming four days a week at night to
answer questions and I haven't I told
you and I haven't I haven't gone live on
my gaming channel since
because when it was away
I didn't miss it
I didn't even feel overwhelm it's not
like oh my God I have too many things
going on where reality like
there's tons going on
but I didn't miss it
and that's not a knock against Drew or
any of the people or whatever like maybe
it just ran its course so maybe I bring
it back in a month but if you take a
little separation from it and then you
realize that I don't actually miss that
thing then you should cut it out from
your life when I went to um the first
time with the Tony Robbins event
he I thought the first time the second
time that when he actually invited me to
come in be his guest
uh they do this fire walk at the end
where you walk on fire and yeah and I
was gonna go because I was Tony's guest
I was going to be the first one on the
fire and he was going to personally be
the guy like yelling at you to come
across the fire not his team like Tony
was going to personally Take Me Out
across the coals and I left I didn't go
do it not a knock against Tony but
what's the point of doing the fire walk
the fire walk is to get you to realize
you can do difficult things and so what
I did was instead was I went back to my
hotel and I I stopped doing four things
that I was doing that involved other
people commitments to other people that
I was doing that I felt bad for them
I felt like I owed them something I felt
like I was doing I didn't want to
disappoint them and so I stayed in
things that I shouldn't have stayed in
and like now is the time to grow and so
I did the that was the real fire walk
for me it was stopping those things
so if you feel overwhelmed by things
um because there's too many things going
on then it's then it's cutting down some
of those things
recognizing what's the priority in your
life
so if it's overwhelmed on the how then
then then stop thinking about it and
just start doing because the house is
going to change million times if it's
the overwhelmed because you have too
many things going on then then it's
cutting down some of the things that you
have going on so you can focus on
building the life that you want to build
and it doesn't mean that like this is
where good is the enemy of great the
things that you if it was if it sucked
you would you would cut it
right like if you went to your women's
group and everybody just yelled at you
the whole time you would leave because
like I don't want to be yelled at all
the time the problem is most of the
things that we're doing they're just
good it's good yeah and the good is
preventing us from doing great things
and so you might have to look at the
calendar and I still do this like I do
this all the time look at my calendar
and saying do I want to keep doing this
should I keep doing Instagram lives
should I keep meeting with the people my
team should I keep like it's a constant
evaluation and you have to be willing to
let go of the good to go for the great
you know it's amazing what you are
saying because you are basically giving
a road map of all the things you know
someone and not only me but anyone who
is undertaken a new a new place in life
all the things that uh you know it can
be done to clarify and to find and to
find a
a clear way to go where you want to go
without feeling
born
and without feeling that you are been
tearing into pieces trying to get your
goal of achieving your dreams and yeah
it's it's kind of like you know
sometimes having that clarity
needs to come from someone else
many many times you kind of know some of
those things but it's good to have
someone telling you having that person
that boy is that mentor and sometimes we
don't look for that we try to do
everything by ourselves as as you were
saying and we start feeling drawn and
and it's it's yeah it's it's a little
bit of what happens to me and what I've
realized happens to many people that
it's going through changes in life uh
undergoing through their personal
Journeys and emotions is something else
that you know all the different emotions
that you experience when you're going
through changes how do you deal with
that I think
it's first up recognizing what is the
emotion where you feel safe
because a lot of times that emotion is
the thing that's actually holding you
back you have to get into the mo the
emotion that makes you feel
uncomfortable so why did I stay in those
things for so long well because it made
me feel safe you know because that's
where home was because I'd rather
be stuck and not grow then potentially
disappoint people
I'd rather stay in these groups and stay
with these commitments that I made
because I don't want to disappoint them
and it's good and it's emotionally hard
to get out of those and move to
something else that I want to do
so it's recognizing what is the emotion
that's keeping you stuck and safe and
how is it actually like it's feeding you
because I don't want to disappoint
people that's the same thing for me I
don't want to support people
um
so it's just shining the light on that
because that's the default my default
mode would be to try to serve and help
people and not disappoint them and that
may actually be holding me back from
doing something much bigger
when you get that like kind of shine on
it whether it's somebody else or whether
it's you
then it's just asking hey is there a way
like if you think about you mentioned
four different groups I think that
you're part of cool like let's say one
of those groups isn't really a great fit
for you anymore maybe it was maybe
you've grown and you learned from it
maybe you're maybe it was never like a
perfect group but now you feel kind of
committed to it is there a way that you
could leave the group
without making everybody feel terrible
and if you pose a question that way
there always is always an answer you
know like is there a way you can leave a
client or leave a relationship or leave
a group or leave a responsibility
without it being terrible
like how can I leave this in as good a
situation as possible if you just take
the time this is what I have to do if I
just take the time to think about it
I can come up with an answer it's like
oh it's actually not that hard to leave
this group and still have them be in a
good spot where they're not hating you
but it's the willingness to ask that
question and
getting through it like it's the it's
the comfort of staying in the group and
feeling like you know you you owe them
something then it's the fear of oh my
gosh if I leave the group they're gonna
hate me
then it's the excitement of okay but if
I free up that time I can go and do
something much bigger and have a bigger
impact right and then it's the Comfort
back to okay I can't actually leave this
group in a way that doesn't
destroy everything for all the people
who are in the group yeah so it's this
range of emotion that we go through but
most of it is the is the fear and the
uncertainty and it almost never ends up
being as bad as you thought it was going
to be because you're not going to leave
the group and say you know what guys
like I hate you and uh it's not working
and you suck and I'm out rather you're
not going to do that
you're gonna find a way to to leave
gracefully and and hopefully give them a
better path forward but we we all have
to like the next level of growth if you
want to go and do amazing things
you need to have time in your calendar
to be able to go off and do it which
means you may have to let go of some
relationships like the friends that you
were with in kindergarten may not be the
same people who are good friends for you
right now maybe you're stuck in a
relationship that's no longer the best
relationship for you maybe you hire
people on your team who aren't good fits
for where you want to grow anymore and
we're okay for where they're at the
number of entrepreneurs they've had to
meet is coaching a guy in San Diego who
who built this business has got a
million dollar company hired five people
they're all his friends and he realized
that like they're not the people that
take him to 10 million
and so he hired his friends and that now
it's not a good fit anymore so he's got
to move on from them and it's hard to
fire your friend yeah
but we have to move on from some of the
relationships and some of the
commitments that we've made
in order to get to the next level
and and yes that's the thing like
because I guess that everyone who
any type of change or journey is because
he feels it's better it's it's good
enough to look for something better in
their lives
so
making that difficult decision you know
finding the way to to manage the fear
and the anxiety and all you know to make
the difficult decision and realize that
doing it it will allow you to be a
better version of yourself you know that
that is
I guess you know what I'm extracting
from you like you know give yourself
that that possibility to to believe that
you can be that you can be it's just a
matter of doing these these things that
you are doing this process analyzing
what is the real you know what are the
reals the real things that I need to be
involved at what are the renunciations
that I have to do even though they are
difficult and uh and you know continue
into that
original idea and original plan original
big dream that you know that that we
have like everyone has right and listen
Community matters too a lot in all of
this like being around people who are
doing a thing or supportive of you when
doing a thing matters you know you look
at what you do if you
for somebody to immigrate to a new
country
that's a lot of that's a hard decision
that's not just like oh yeah let's move
to Canada like it's for most people
you're leaving your home you're leaving
your family you're leaving your
community you're leaving you have to
learn a whole new language being a whole
new country and understand all the new
laws and there's that's a that's a tough
choice
for a lot of people doing that is harder
than almost anything else you know
leaving everything behind and going to a
new country
what makes it easier
is being around people who've also
immigrated to that country
you know it's like if you move to a new
country and you're all by yourself
you're all alone you have no friends
nobody speaks your language nobody
understands your culture you're just
sitting in your basement of your new
rental home or apartment all day long
you're like that's a that's a really
dangerous Narrow Path what helps is
people meeting people like kindness you
know meeting people who are who are in
the community make people who've also
moved to a new country you know people
supporting you on the new Journey so
it's about being around the people
because if you're around your family and
the people you know your old friends or
where you came from what are they going
to say stay here don't go there stay
here this is where everything is at but
you know you want to go there so the
people who were with you back there they
want you to stay with them
but you need people for where you're
going
and being around those people more will
will help give you the courage and the
motivation and the inspiration as well
as the tactics and the tools and the
introductions but the feeling that
you're not alone because when you leave
a place this is where I said like we're
all immigrants even if you were born in
the country you're at because to leave a
place
where you feel like you belong and now
you're going to a new place where you
don't belong
is really scary and that's a main reason
why a lot of people never make that
Journey because they don't want to do it
alone so they'd rather stay safe and
comfortable and in a community where
they belong then go off and try to find
something new so a lot of people stay in
a broken relationship because they're
afraid that they won't find anybody else
and so rather be with somebody who is
abusive or neglectful then be with
nobody right we feel like we can't get
to the next spot because uh we're stuck
where we are and so just being just the
importance of community like whatever
you're trying to do
don't do it alone
find people even if it doesn't mean that
the person you find is going to be your
best friend for life
but in joining communities in being a
part of the thing that where you're
going you will find your tribe and
looking back you know in five years or
ten years later be like I can't believe
that's who I used to be I'm so glad I
continued on the journey yeah yeah and
something that you you used to say you
say a lot and I love it because it has
helped me so much is when you are in
doubt when you have you're not sure
about what to decide
um big decisions with your with your
heart small decisions with your head yes
and uh and that has been so like such a
big
um guide for me uh since years ago like
when I started listening about you and
uh when you know when I need to make
those kind of decisions I use that that
principle big decisions with your heart
and small decisions with your head uh
because in the end
um there's a biggest knowledge right
that goes beyond the intellect and
that's definitely something that we can
use so it's something that I I try to to
lean on and Community definitely it's uh
it's something that we all we all can
use and as immigrants we definitely need
a strong Community strong Community as a
person as an individuals to like me
being part of movement makers helps me
so much in many sense and uh you know
being around you having this opportunity
talking to you it's definitely and you
know extracting those little things or
big things and big thoughts that may
help me definitely are helping me and
will help many other people that you
know that can listen to this I've been
checking all the hearts and all the
comments and I'm just so grateful that
you know that you share all this with us
with me and yeah thank you so much an
easy way to look at is you know if
you're feeling overwhelmed by the amount
of work that you're doing you look at
the calendar and just look at the day
ahead or look at the week ahead and what
in your calendar
gets you excited and what in your
calendar makes you like oh my God
like that's a heart decision right it
may make super logical sense to you to
do that thing but if it if it sinks your
energy then it's not worth doing long
term doesn't mean you quit it right now
but you know you have to get out of that
thing longer term when I look at my
calendar I see Tanya Gonzalez in the
house like let's go it's gonna be fun
you know if I look at like oh Tanya no
you know then and then I shouldn't be
doing ubering I should be doing
something completely different right I
look at it I'm excited so I should keep
I should keep doing it right and so if
you look at your calendar we tend to We
tend to prioritize just the things that
make sense but if you feel like you're
at the end of every day and you're super
drained and you have no energy and and
you need like a huge break to deal with
everything that you just went through
today well maybe you're doing the wrong
stuff you know like and and doing the
right things may not make sense yet but
having time on your calendar to at least
cut out some of the things that are
making you feel low energy and replacing
them with things that you can get cited
by even if they don't work out short
term that's the path to creating the new
life that you want to create so don't
make a list of pros and cons like should
I do this or not
pros and cons because you're trying to
make a big decision with your head it's
like no which one which one do you love
more like which one is more exciting for
you to go off and try because if you do
the work that makes you feel excited and
gives you energy like I have more energy
leaving you than coming into you like
you are you gave me energy you didn't
take away my energy and hopefully the
same for you you know hopefully you're
leaving so this is like two plus two
equals eight thousand because you're
you're combining things and we're we're
both leaving I'm assuming more energetic
than than when we came in right so it's
like a sign that you're doing the right
thing and if you're leaving if you're
leaving tasks feeling depleted you
should not be doing that long term again
it doesn't mean you quit that thing
right now it doesn't mean you quit the
relationship or the job or the
partnership or whatever like in the
moment maybe you do but at least having
a plan to get out there because you
don't want to explain the next five ten
years of your life doing nothing that
you hate and I guess that also helps you
with guilt like not building feeling
guilty about making those hard decisions
like you know having in front of you the
possibility of growth like yes I'm
cutting all these but in the future I
will have all these other
chances open to me because I'm making
this difficult decision at this moment
which you know I think that for many
people it's something like that you feel
guilty about making those hard decisions
because you will affect someone else and
it's hard to make that decision it goes
you know beyond you it's not only you're
not even thinking on you but in you what
you're saying like in you giving
yourself that chance to grow sooner or
later you will benefit many more
yeah if you want to reduce the guilt of
dropping something you do two things you
either
raise how much excitement you have for
what's coming so you raise the level of
well if I free up this time I can go
build this and I can help that and then
I can have this impact because I have
this extra time so we're raising the
excitement for the future that you've
got and then also how do you lower the
risk of something bad happening so you
have you got two things to pull like I'm
going to get more excited about the life
that I'm going to build and I'm going to
reduce the impact of me leaving so again
you're not just going to lead the group
and say that's it I'm out you guys suck
have fun like how do you leave we just
never asked a question like how do I
leave this group or leave this person in
a way that reduces the downside as much
as possible it may not be zero like if
we're gonna get rid of a client we try
to pass them on to somebody else where
it might be a better fit not just hey
you suck you're out like try to give
them a better path out yeah
um so both of those get excited about
the future and lower the downside as
much as possible and it gives you the
freedom to go in and build and make and
create because
where most people get stuck is just the
complacency of staying where you are
because it's comfortable and it's safe
and it's what you know as opposed to
getting out into the unknown but that's
where all of the magic happens like the
magic doesn't happen by you staying who
you are oh yeah magic happens by you
changing and growing this and that's not
an option because yeah it may be
comfortable I always think that Comfort
is that song that it's warm and nice but
it will burn at the end it will take the
best of you at the end so that's not an
option never never you know just we need
to make that that that leap of faith I I
have I've always wondered something have
you ever thought like in your past you
know when you were very young and when
you were dealing with all the things
that you've dealt until you've shared
with us right about all the you know the
the doves about you uh you being able to
do all what you're doing
have you ever or did you ever thought
that you will find greatness
did you ever felt that inside you that
you know I have to keep going because I
feel that there's something so big
inside of me that I need to give myself
the chance to keep going because I'm
gonna be great
only to the extent that I think
everybody has that okay you know and
maybe that's because my mom was my hero
or I'm Canadian or whatever you know
yeah maybe that's like just baked into
us but
um yes and I think that
I think that everybody has the Michael
Jordan level Geniuses something like
everybody is great at something you're
the best in the world is something and
we've gotta we gotta find out what that
thing is and you got to dedicate the
time to to then practice in it and
actually getting really great at it's
like believing that you even can be
great and then believe in yourself
enough to chase down that dream
um I think really really matters so uh
yes I believe I'm great I believe you're
great I believe everybody watching here
is great at something and then the
tricky part is this is why everybody is
an immigrant like it's not what you were
born into you know like you what you're
great at is not what your parents did
for living it's not what you went to
school to learn it's not what any of
your friends are doing it's something
completely different
and it takes a lot of courage to go off
and leave the comfort of your home to
then go and like you stay in in your
little village or you go and build a
castle you know most people just stay in
their little village where like you
everybody can have their own castle it's
like you can but it takes a lot of
courage to walk that path and yeah you
always say something else that I like I
like a lot is it's a muscle you know
being being uh being brave it's a muscle
that we can develop and making those
difficult decisions it's something that
you we can work on doing more and more
and it's going to be more and you know
easier every time and yeah 100 like I
remember when when you joined uh our
insiders group so we have a for anybody
who buys any of my books we have a
Facebook group that we meet
um and we have events kind of once a
week for free if you got the book uh and
Tanya joined one of the first sessions
but didn't say anything the first time
to joined just kind of sat there and
watched and then and then I think the
second time or the third time you like a
little question and now here you are
you're going live it's like imagine look
at all the content you've made all the
live streams you've done all the people
you've helped all the videos that you
like Tanya from I don't know how long
ago that was a year and a bit ago maybe
I may around may may last year like look
at even even just in so that's what a
year and a half or a year and a couple
months like how much growth you've had
I made this this year made this year
yeah this year it was last year yeah
no I just got surgery yeah in April 2022
I had surgery and after that I I became
a movement maker
in April
wow okay so if that's insane so even
just look at that like look at how much
you've grown since April May
if you showed yourself this like if if
we went back to February Tanya and said
hey look at what you did in October
that's not me that's not happening
there's no way there's no way and that's
only a few months later yeah now imagine
what you can do in a year two years or
five years or ten years it's crazy
you're literally an impossibility like
Tanya from March would think that Tanya
from October is impossible because I can
never do that it's impossible
and yet you've already done it in a
really tight window
it's it's part of being the right in the
right community that that made such a
big difference for me that I I remember
you saying I'm an introvert I'm an
introvert and I'm you know I've been
able to evolve myself to do all these
things that are not likely for a person
who's an introvert and I'm a shy person
so I said okay you know this person can
do it and it's not comparing myself to
anyone but you know it is possible to
give that switch to your
to your personality to character we are
not Define what by what we are at this
moment like we are really not I really
believe that and I've made many changes
in my life and this last phase in my
life you know doing these big
um opening myself to do all these things
like it has given me some so much
fulfillment and a sense of
um a sense of uh confidence and
gratitude and uh it's it's really like
yes I feel myself as an example that you
can change and I'm committed to live
that shy girl like you know at the side
I know that she exists I know that she
is there but I don't want her to Define
me and I know that there's more people
everyone can do it it's just you know
surrounding with the right people and
finding those those possibilities to to
Really find your potential so I'm very
grateful that I found you your community
because it has made a big difference in
my life yeah showing movement makers
during our challenge right the first
filter serve challenge
wow I thought it was at least a year
no but it's only been like four or five
months
uh yeah I think so yeah it's was that
around April April this year right May
June July August September and it's got
October 3rd yeah so we're into our sixth
that's crazy yeah and yeah I've
experienced so many changes like in my
life I would have thought that I would
be doing this because I was so private
that I not even my Facebook was to I was
an active not even in Facebook so even
learning all these has been such a big
experience so having the right
motivation makes all the difference in a
p on someone's life regular life because
I'm you know
quiet person like you know I just like
little things like I like dance outside
like my work I like working with
immigrants I like those kind of things
but you know learning about all these
possibilities gave me such a different
insight about what can I do and how can
I help and why should I help
and why should I not keep everything to
myself but sometimes I feel overwhelmed
and sometimes I feel like I question
myself you know should I go back to a
more quiet life should I you know just
take it a little bit easier but
something inside me tells me no
well listen it's never going back like
if you make a if you make a shift or a
change it's never going back it's just
going somewhere else yeah you know it's
like the the caterpillar becomes the
butterfly
the butterfly never goes back to
becoming a caterpillar
um but the butterfly also doesn't stay
on the same tree forever yeah the
butterfly flies away and goes other
places so it's never going back like you
never want to be the Tanya who you used
to be there's nothing wrong with her she
helped you get to where you are now but
we never go back you're just lying
somewhere else but but the butterflies
wants to fly you know the butterfly
doesn't stay stuck the caterpillar's
stuck you know the caterpillar's stuck
on the tree
becomes a butterfly and then the
butterfly flies away so
um
anyway I'm just still stuck on the
you've only been with us for five months
like I'm so excited to see what you're
doing the next five years this is crazy
Tanya let's go
you know I I see like all the time I
have so many you know thoughts and plans
and ideas and now that I've done a
little bit I believe
using your you know your core I believe
that I can do much more and uh not only
you know that will be in benefit of
myself but also in benefit of everyone
that I can touch uh something I you
always said is uh not always is willing
to hear something from uh
a specific person but it's open to hear
it from someone else
and you know I really want to tap into
that because I may be able to you know
to to give a little bit of Hope
inspiration a loving push for so many
people who is waiting on the dog
you know on the port not deciding to
Embark in their Journeys so I hope I can
give them that little bit of tools to
make their Journey easy because it is
possible it is possible for regular
people to make
things that you know are a little bit
extraordinary yeah and listen you
started that scene I may be able to you
definitely will and you already are
you know like you already are you you
already are doing it we we had um we had
our clubhouse session the other day on
the on the weekend to kind of celebrate
people who finished the challenge and a
woman joined and
she was talking about how she was so
kind of introverted and shy and you know
couldn't speak and would never get
making videos and now she's like how do
I help inspire people I think but you
were like you're here you're already
doing it you already are
you're you've already helped tons of
people they may not be where you end up
right like you may think oh it's nothing
compared to what other people are doing
but you've already had an impact
on people's lives and it's only going to
scale and get bigger and grow more
so it's it's just perspective a lot of
times we're so worried about where we're
going
that we haven't taken the time to look
back and say oh I was over there that's
crazy
which helps with the overwhelm as well
it helps with the it helps with the
Imposter syndrome it helps with the I'm
not good enough you think well I'm not
Oprah or I'm not whoever you know
whoever you hear is I'm not I'm not that
big yet
you know when do I start sharing but
like you've already you've already had
an impact you're already dealing
so on the days when you feel
uh this is what I do a lot with the
people on my team and the entrepreneurs
I've invested into most of the work is
making them see how awesome they are
um there are some days you know Alex
comes in uh and he says like he's the
greatest instructor in the world then
I'll I'll knock him down he's like dude
you suck like you're just getting
started but on most of the days is
coming in with the I'm not good enough
energy he's like look how far you've
come like Alex from five years ago who
walked in and was like the worst dancer
in his class look at what you've become
and so we often forget the perspective
to see the journey that we've climbed
and every time you take that step you
can go help somebody else's stuck at
Step Zero yeah and that you know that
teaching of you to treat ourselves with
uh Grace
you know to to to be kind to ourselves
it's uh so like so so important because
otherwise it's falling twice not only
you you know you you failed at doing
something but you come and you treat
yourself bad that's falling twice so
yeah it's it's it's very nice that that
you're saying you know treat yourself
this is where like a great Community or
great mentor can help because when
you're there's no
there's no one answer like sometimes you
need to be lifted up when you feel
really low you need to be lifted up
and when you feel on top of the world
that you feel you know too egomaniac you
need to be brought back down
you know it's like you need to you're
just getting started get to work go you
think you you think you ask Ross if you
suck let's go but most of the time it's
the opposite where the needs like dude
you're amazing you know
you've done so much and so having
um
having the support of people and mentors
to kind of guide and hug you when you
need it and push you where you need it I
think it's really valuable and you're
doing that for other people too
thank you thank you so much to see me
coach another entrepreneur one on one
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there so first off I
wouldn't stream anything to YouTube so
on your channel here you've got some
videos it's great I wouldn't do it as
streamed I would just upload it as a
regular video because streamed videos
get a lot less long-term views on
content